we have some potentially good news about
the infrastructure and spending bill duo
and the news is that it appears
kirsten cinema's office is saying
and senate majority leader chuck schumer
seems to be confirming that prescription
drug price controls may be back in the
bill now on monday we played video
and audio i mean it'd be weird to just
play video with no audio we played audio
and video of bernie being interviewed
over the weekend bernie sanders senator
from vermont saying
i'm still working on the prescription
drug price stuff
and my hope is that we're going to be
able to get it in the bill so let's look
at what we learned in the last 24 hours
kirsten cinema putting out a statement
cinema office statement on historic
medicare drug negotiation agreement
a quote from john la bombard kirsten
cinema's communications director after
senator cinema reached earlier agreement
with president biden to include historic
medicare drug negotiation in the
reconciliation package policies that
were omitted from the initial framework
at the request of members of the house
speaker pelosi reached out to senator
cinema this past weekend to continue
negotiations the senator welcomes a new
agreement on a historic transformative
medicare drug negotiation plan that will
reduce out-of-pocket costs for seniors
ensuring drug prices cannot rise faster
than inflation save taxpayer dollars and
protect innovation to ensure arizonans
and americans continue to have access to
life-saving medications and new cures
and therapeutics um we also thank
representatives peters and schroeder for
their work on this historic agreement so
there were questions like what the hell
is going on here we then heard from
senate majority leader chuck schumer
agreeing they are doing this let's go to
some clips of chuck schumer
i'm pleased to announce that an
agreement has been reached to lower
prescription drug prices for seniors and
families in the build back better
legislation
fixing prescription drug pricing has
consistently been a top issue for
americans year after year
including the vast majority of both
democrats and republicans continuing uh
was
chuck schumer to say
um
more specifics about what it is that's
been negotiated and the direction things
may be going here
by empowering medicare to directly
negotiate prices in part b and part d
this deal will directly reduce
out-of-pocket drug spending for millions
of patients every time they visit the
pharmacy or doctor
it will cap out of pocket spending at 2
000 per year
ending the days where a life-changing
diagnosis could mean thousands upon
thousands of dollars in new expenses
okay so some specifics there
and then um just a few more details here
from senate minority senate majority
leader chuck schumer
and senator um
cinema right
has told me she supports this agreement
so i think we're there
it's not everything we all wanted
many of us would have wanted to go much
further yeah but it's a big step in
helping the american people deal with
the price of drugs right
so uh i mean listen should we be happy
that something related to controlling
prescription drug prices is presumably
going to be in the bill
yes yeah i mean we could be happy about
that that that's okay that's reasonable
um should we be furious that this was
even a debate
and that it's one of the many things in
addition to
paid leave
more environmental regulated all the
different things we talked about
medicare expansion that was pulled from
these bills
yes it's dystopian and disturbing that
we're even having these negotiations
today no question about that
um should progressives still
kill the bill as i suggested last week
maybe they they should do
listen you guys know that i'm the
ultimate pragmatist
in the past i've taken heat for saying
don't kill a bill because it contains
some good stuff
last week i said
the bills have now been so gutted
maybe it is time to kill the bill
because what we mostly have are sort of
like infrastructure slush funds for
corporations etc and i said maybe it is
and then a bunch of people became
furious for me saying yeah real
pragmatic pacman killing a bill that
actually has stuff in it that makes
sense um
my position at this point is
if this can be passed soon in the next
few weeks so that it's truly done before
the house and senate recess for the end
of the year
and it does have some climate-related
elements in it
and it does have some worthwhile
infrastructure spending and it now has
some although not nearly what we would
like to see um prescription drug price
controls
i i say pass it
but i think
whether the individual bill is killed
or passes as it would likely pass given
what we understand about it now
it's not going to be enough to save
democrats in 2022. so on balance would i
rather some things be passed than not
yes yes i would
um is it
potentially even going to be like a
pyrrhic victory for democrats to some
degree yeah it may be it's not going i
mean listen we looked at what happened
yesterday with the results passing a
milk toast bill
is not going to be nearly enough to vote
to motivate democratic voters in a year
to vote in the november of 22 midterms
compared with the effectiveness that we
know
the fomenting of anger and the fomenting
of fear on cultural issues by
republicans will have on their
electorate so pass the bill sure you
know i'm not going out there and saying
kill it it's just more an exercise in
frustration as to how long this has been
going on and how much weaker and weaker
and weaker the bill is now it's gotten
slightly less weak with the addition of
the prescription drug controls um
okay pass it fine but if anybody thinks
this is what's going to save democrats
in 2022 oh no no no no and yesterday's
election results
across the country
should be a reminder of that we're going
to take a quick break we'll have more
coverage of this on the david pakman
show instagram which you can find at
david pakman show you can find me on
instagram at david.pacman after the
break we'll be talking about a new poll
from the prri public
religion research institute i believe it
is
um telling us that 30 of republicans now
openly support using violence to achieve
their political goals
my question is how many support it but
don't openly say it so we'll talk about
that after the break and much much more
one of our sponsors is shaker and spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
delivering ingredients and recipes for
artisanal cocktails i've been using
shaker at spoon to make cocktails at
home the last two drinks i made were
citrus paradisi because i'm a big vodka
fan
and sea fog with rum the whole
experience begins when you open the box
everything looks really nice they
include all the ingredients you need
except the alcohol
with easy instructions i've been really
impressed with the results even if you
know nothing about mixing drinks like me
you will have a ton of success creating
the cocktails that shaker and spoon
sends you and you learn about mixology
in the process and widen your horizons
it's the perfect thing to do for a date
night i've had a ton of fun with it i
think you will too and you'll get 20 off
when you use promo code pacman at
checkout go to shakerandspoon.com
pacman the link is down below